prove this so this is a harder country
but I also gave you a clue I gave you an
identity a rather obvious one but
sometimes you don't get given that clue
and have you been shown how it sort of
works and the basic method you'll be
expected to sort of work out that step
on your own okay but since we're just
sort of doing this at the beginning let
me rehearse what the point was what was
the what was the clue I think there's
one plus X to the 8th right yeah and if
you do that again
just by your index laws that's equal to
[ __ ] okay so obviously even without
knowing very much you can see there's
some connection between this and it's
like that 16 that 16 that seems kind of
interesting so how can we use it well
let me ask you this learning that the
coefficients here right they're not like
twos or threes or fives or anything like
that so you're just going to get
Pascal's triangle right you're just
going to get those numbers and they're
not going to be skewed or adjusted by
any other coefficients yeah so that
being the case what is the significance
of this number so this series because
that's an except it's an expansion it's
a series right where does this number up
here here
this that's right something out shall we
well what do we get over I'm gonna move
this to the middle of the board because
that's what they need to be when I
expand our 1 plus X to the 16th okay
what's the very first term 16th right
okay 16 to 0 okay and then you just got
a 1 and because it's always gonna go on
it's not even negative 1 I can just not
worry about writing it next term 16
choose one and the x's are going up on
that kind of second times X to the 1 X
to the 2 and so on okay so you can see
that 16 choose 8 is going to appear when
I get to the X to the eighth term that
makes sense and that's what the last
term it does keep on going all the way
up to 60 inches 16 and it'll be X's you
see that's what your feature okay so
being that I know that this 16 shows it
is going to line up here what I then
have to do is work out well where is
this something choose a sorry where is
the X to the a a PR out of here
right now because this is the same thing
twice I'm just going to get rid of your
second one and say square it okay now
what does it expansion look on the left
hand side well let's do this again just
like here right I'm gonna get a choose
know what just 1 and choose 1 and 1 1 X
8 choose 2 - lots of ads yes right and
so on until the last term which is a
chose 8 okay
now that whole thing is yeah even though
I haven't written it you can see that
that's square means there's a second row
and we're gonna do that same thing we
did with the grant in the red the green
and the red cars before because saw
these terms when I max filled with the
next one I multiply that some of them
won't give me
what kinds of combinations will give me
X to the a well for instance if I just
say okay for instance let's start with
this term over here H is not okay
because there are no X's on it I need to
pair it up with an X to the N right now
that's gonna be in this term on the end
so I'm gonna get a choose naught and H 8
right and that's gonna have an X to the
8th oh no right really a long one if I
choose this one
a choose one okay it's got one X someone
need to match it up with maybe if I try
and cram it in here there'll be a choose
7 X 4 7 right so you can see where this
path is going yeah in fact by the end
I'm gonna get back to this a Tuesday I'm
going to say well which term in the
first series will it match on with in
the second series and it's going to be
I'll have a choose 8 and that's gone and
I need to match it up with the first
term of the next year ok which happens
to videos ok so now because you can see
look at this term here and this term
here right
it's doubled up can you see that I've
got the overlap so you see how this
relates to this what's that mean you've
got for instance let's actually write
some of these terms out okay I've got a
2-0 that's the first instance of our and
because I'm squaring it I've got a true
zero again okay then the next one will
be a trues one and they choose one again
and so on all the way up to this second
that isn't quite what we've got in here
is it or is it what identity can use
here
help you out yeah that's right
this is zero this eight it's one in the
seven two and six and so on they're all
the same distance from the ends and from
the middle okay so I can actually write
down let's see here I really use this
sort of extra working so that's I'm just
I'm just going to keep going coefficient
what are they going to be equal to I'm
just gonna rewrite it so that I can
justify going from here to here okay so
eight choose naught is equal to eight
choose eight - [ __ ] said okay you see
how that's I'm going from there to there
because that's the number that I've got
the time okay I just want the
coefficients on the leave the X term I'm
gonna have eight choose one and then
this is equal to H choose 8 minus 7
which is the one that I need and so on
all the way up to here about 8 shoes 8 +
H 8 - 8 again different weights sorry
hey buddy 0 sorry thank you okay so now
I have my numbers the exactly lining up
by the way that's kind of a even though
I probably say this a lot it seems like
a trivial step okay but because the show
right you already know what you're gonna
get to it you can't you can't cut out
steps okay you've got to demonstrate you
know exactly where all right so that's a
true zero squared H is 1 squared and so
on all up to H is 8 squared and you can
just rewrite that in Sigma notation
okay now probably the last thing that I
need to say is really in here I sort of
got away with it by doing this I should
say by comparison of the coefficient of
x da ya that's 16 Tuesday with the
coefficient of x da over here which I've
just now worked out to be that therefore
they said that he is true okay but Casey
house that would shed all the main work
is there and the rest is just how you
presented